all right ali
yes ali uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally borah heights
used to lie yes or near east china tell
me about your family you had both your
parents when you were kids
yeah both my parents at home
it was kind of [ __ ] up on my back
excuse me
it's okay it was messed up but um yeah
how would you describe your chocolate
horrible
[Music]
i don't describe it as a childhood it
was taken from me
so my dad abused me and
started what kind of stuff went on he
was sexually abused me in the closet
made me eat dog food killed my cat
i couldn't have an animal because he
would kill it because i love animals
like he would kill my
my animals like my rabbits and any any
little animal i would get he would just
kill it
right in front of me and the sexual
abuse went on for how long until i was
like 13
when i was 13 i got pregnant with your
father
yeah i had my son
he says he's 27 now
i don't see him i didn't i didn't raise
him
he he got raised with somebody else like
another family
you know but i see him as an adult now
but i don't really
see him i don't really know him you know
um my dad got really sick and died
and i was happy because i hated him
and my mom she's still alive but i don't
even see her either
because she let it all happen
and um after i had my son i started
doing drugs
and a lot of drugs started smoking crack
i started smoking um pcp
and drinking and just i was just out
there
and um every boyfriend i would get they
were all abusive
i was like i was like drawn to that you
know and so
as an adult now i ended up down here
because
i had i was married to a a man for 13
years
i got married actually but he abused me
throughout the whole 13 years so
i finally finally left him and i left
them
seven years ago and i ended up living
down here
and i had a normal life well you can't
normal
but um i lost my job i lost my job and i
had a boyfriend another boyfriend
he went to prison and i ended up out
here by myself we were here together but
then he
went to prison and left me out here and
then left me out here with the wolves
and i didn't know anybody out here i
didn't even know where the store was at
you know i was scared to be outside now
it's like
i'm outside it's real it gets real out
here
you know but at the end of the day i'm
still surviving you know
and um some people have it worse or
stuff but
i don't know i just i don't wish that
upon anybody because
what do you think helps you survive
being grateful like a grateful attitude
for still being here because i'm still
having my mind
i still have my mind right i guess you
know i'm kind of learning too but
are you still using yes i still use i
use i use crystal myth
yeah and it's just me and my dog and i
have a cat
actually i have two cats now but seeing
it's just me and them
nobody else any other children no
i have three grandkids i don't haven't
seen them
but i know i know of them and um i have
two little sisters
they're not little no more but they were
younger than me yeah they didn't go
through
none of that stuff my mom separated from
my dad when i was 17.
so they were they were lucky
yeah do you feel like you were ever
loved no
not by your family not by anyone else
i don't know what that is how about you
how about by yourself well
i'm starting to do that i guess you know
my goal is to get out of the street you
know but um
i know my dog loves me
that's genuine love right there you know
it is real
yeah i can't deny that so
how'd you end about skid row because i
left my apartment because i had my job
he lost his job my boyfriend at the
moment
and so we ended up saying we said let's
just put a tent up that should be
temporary
and it's been three years now yeah
what do you do for money now sometimes i
have dates
sometimes i just get blessed or i
recycle
i don't like people so i rather recycle
you know but sometimes it's not as easy
a sucker comes along you know
if i pay you extra can i have you take
the sunglasses on all right
you know make me show my face so when
did you first get into drugs
um when after after i had my son
yeah i was like 14. i started smoking
primos
do you see that my boyfriend at the time
he introduced me a whole life of drugs
how to sell drugs
cut drugs back it up everything yeah
but um yeah i did that for a long time
i feel like i've been doing drugs for
like 40 years
that's how it feels but i don't think
it's been that long
maybe 20 maybe 20. do you have any
friends
i have constituents acquaintances
acquaintances yep
yep out here i don't know i don't know
what friends are do you trust anyone
no no you're smart i don't
uh sometimes i don't go to church like
right now that i left my dog i lifted
the neighbor hey watch my dog you know i
gotta trust that right now
taking a chance you know but i need that
i need that i'm getting robbed right now
while you're talking to me
i hope not because i will go postal
right now that's how it works right here
i'm the quiet one in
the block i'm the quiet one the one that
you know nobody just leave me alone
but if you mess with my dog i don't
guarantee you survive
what stresses you out what do you worry
about i stress about my peace of mind
like
i don't like people messing with me you
know talking they're not
talking on the side of their neck they
don't tell me directly so just say it
like if they're passing by my channel
they'll just say something and say my
name like i want to change my name so
bad
am i can i just change my name because i
hear my name you know it was talking
about me like what the [ __ ]
because they're curious i guess i don't
know what the [ __ ] i said my name must
taste good
with all the stuff you've gone through
in your life what what emotions do you
deal with now
anger anger it would make sense
but i don't project it
i'm hoping i don't but a lot of people
don't like me
maybe i do project anger or attitude i
don't know
but they say they say oh ali she's nice
she's nice you know she's nice
i'd rather be nice i'd rather be nice
what's the most most important lesson
you've learned in your life
i've learned a lot of lessons but um
most
respect importantly a long way
respect yourself
when you're a young girl do you have
dreams of doing something with your life
how old you think i am
43. i'm going to be 43 this month
good guess yeah i don't know what i want
to do
i just know that i want to get out of
the street and get a job and
get myself there i want to actually get
a mobile home
and do like a like a like a store
slash bike shop mobile you know i don't
know or maybe catering i don't know
something it'd be great
yeah i don't know i like i sing too i
used to sing
but right now like it's hard right now
after the holidays it's like the
depression is barely leaving you know
yeah the holidays make it tough yeah do
you feel like what you went through with
your father
and maybe your lack of support from your
mom
kind of just set the path that you're on
yeah
i think so i'm sure of that
yeah it's got to affect you in some way
it does
it does but out here i learned to hide
my emotions
because when i first got out here oh my
god over my heart in my sleeve you know
and people take advantage of that so i
just like
learned to not do you feel betrayed by
your family yeah
yeah yeah ultimate ultimately betrayal
you can't trust nobody if i can't trust
you you can't trust your parents who can
you trust right
you know i trust my dog that's the only
one i trust
he trusts me so i don't break trust if
you trust me with your [ __ ]
your shit's gonna be all right actually
i was doing that as a job
you know sometimes people watch my [ __ ]
watch my dope
watch my tent and it'll pay me you know
gotta hustle somehow
but yeah you still have hope yeah that
life will be fair to you i still have
hope
yeah yeah yeah i do i'm a pisces
i feel everything you know but
i learned to cope with it by using
crystal meth
what does crystal meth do for you it
helps me cope with [ __ ]
you know it kind of numbs me a little
helps me to
get up and do something is crystal meth
as addictive as crack
um i think crack is more addictive
but it's a different height
crystal meth is more mental and it's
like a mood
like a mood enhancer and it lasts longer
and it's cheaper yeah and um
i don't know i'm a lot more and more i'm
a lot due to all that that i went to
went through
i became like real introvert like i'm
always to me to me inside me i look at
me first he's like i was wondering
what the [ __ ] did i do you know yeah
like what did i do
you know but that makes me do with
everything every situation that i go
through i i reflect on myself first
you know because maybe it's something
i'm doing wrong i don't know
you know i try my best to
not [ __ ] with people i think there's
probably a balance between taking
responsibility for
exactly everything in your life as well
as seeing
clearly that what your father did to you
and what your family
may be allowed to happen yeah he's not
it's kind of out of your way i mean i
had to go to therapy and say you know
but that's what that helped me was
therapy helpful yeah
yeah i'm gonna start therapy again
because you know
i'm taking um depression pills so
[Music]
but my worker she sucks
but yeah i'm coping with [ __ ]
[Music]
i feel like you know i don't really make
a big deal about it because
there's so many women out here that been
through a lot of [ __ ] abuse
my bad again so it's like common you
know it's common yeah
it's it's it's messed up it's shocking
how men
and it's like the women i see
[ __ ] different than people i don't just
tell everybody how i see [ __ ] you know
but
i've learned to recognize [ __ ] and i
like to differentiate things like
love i don't really know what love is
but i know loving sex
you know some women do feel that because
they have sex with a guy that the guy
loves
loves them i don't i'm like
you love me you're going to stimulate my
mind you know because i'm not stupid you
know i'm smart
i read i like to read and i'm an
information hoarder
you know so i can just be with you you
know
a lot of women out here they ran out my
neighbor she's like the dude don't even
want her and
she's right there getting sucked up and
[ __ ]
and it's a very hard environment just to
exist in because everybody's up to no
good
yeah everybody everybody around you
including you or yeah yeah
like right now when i was walking over
here i'm like what the [ __ ]
i walk in here and i what the hell was
behind that i'm the only person in all
of skid row it's not up to no good i'm
like who is behind there
and then that's and that's still to be
determined is this
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you made me take my glasses
off
i did yeah see see how i am
yep you're
what good that what was the best time of
your life
um
when i was sober i was sober for six
years are you working yeah
off of crack off of meth christmas yeah
and i was living with my boyfriend that
was like the best
time with him yeah we were living
together how did you get off of crystal
man
i went to a rehab to a home to a
christian home
uh women's home mm-hmm yeah how long
were you in there
for a year three years yeah yeah i was
all diehard christian
and i was in the worship team
but um and then i woke up
and i just see that as a stepping stone
to my spiritual life
yeah i'm like spiritual
trying to be human you know
[Music]
yeah but we don't know
a lot of [ __ ] i like i can't talk about
two people because they don't know what
the
hell i'm talking about you know certain
individuals that i
that do know you know you ever talk
about what you've talked about here with
other people
no not really only like one or two pers
people hell no i don't like people
knowing me
that's too intimate yeah does it feel
good dude
it felt good but it's kind of scary
who's going to watch this
hey i think i think it's therapeutic
yeah well thank you brother's and
it i'll foreign like i'm just leaving it
alone
i don't know maybe i will i don't know
no honestly it goes over really well on
my channel
people are just forthcoming i'll see you
but i'll hear it like
they're just waiting for you to show
some weakness you know
i don't know i think i think it works
the other way yeah i understand what
you're thinking
yeah but i think it actually works yeah
the other way
let's see what happens people open their
hearts for yeah people don't even have
hearts down here we're in hell
yeah it's pretty don't sound scary as
hell
it is our hearts are frozen
all right ellie thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you and i wish
you the best of luck with whatever you
do from here
yeah thank you very much and thank you
for taking off your glasses okay
you